welcome to collector mania you enjoying
your day so far meeting all the fans the
fans are really nice they're really
sweet as I'm having a good time I listen
to a Walking Dead fan podcast they
called them the wild dogs do you think
it's a good description of Joe's group
of men oh I think that's that's very
pejorative actually they weren't wild
dogs they were very they were very tamed
dogs within certain parameters just
don't get on their bad side the rule was
in there which he claimed was a big
thing about the name of an episode as
well so how do you think Joe seemed to
think he isn't a bad guy he's just a
product of the circumstances anything
yeah I mean the world imagine this place
was filled with zombies and you have to
survive you know and it's like the end
of the world the world is over now what
are you gonna do to survive that's
that's a huge question and you know and
they at least had an answer it may not
have been an ideal answer for other
people but for them at work you're
saying you go down that same route in
that situation not even a little bit no
but but I could I could understand how
someone would you know especially
someone that you know these these are
men who you know Joe was probably like
mechanic or something before you know he
wasn't a terribly deep thinker but he
knows what it is to be a man he knows
what it is to be alive and and he has a
strong survival instinct and you know
when the survival instinct comes up you
gotta listen to it you know so there was
a lot of mystery around Joe and his guys
he initially kind of came in that house
and Rick was under the bed
it looked like Rick might end up in
trouble and then you with Daryl Dixon
fill up the time he's obviously that the
fan favorite character were you aware of
that that people were worried you were
going to hurt Daryl yeah the people were
coming up to me on the street and they
had t-shirts on that said killed Daryl
and we riot you know and so yeah as I
was very careful to take pretty good
care of Daryl just funny then I'll talk
about your death your death is probably
the best death on the walking dead so
far I'm looking at your neck now it
looks alright but how did was it filming
that scene what did you use what kind of
prosthetics and how was it filming that
scene well they sold it mostly by Andrew
Lincoln
filling his mouth with fake blood and
raw chicken and so he would
come in and then go out and spit and and
then they just there was one shot then
where there was a I had a prosthetic on
with you know blood to be pumped out of
it and it was very cold and
uncomfortable and you late at night in
Georgia and it was 4:00 in the morning
and you didn't have sweet Road chicken
yourself so you can't really come I did
not have the raw chicken in my that was
his choice man but that had guys
committed he's really committed Brit
commitment that that's what we like he's
he's a wonderful actor and and he you
know what that guy because of the way he
is on the set everyone else is having a
good time I mean he'd never complained
so no one else ever complains and he's
the one who goes through the most so so
yeah you had a massive impact I'm
walking dead but what's next for you now
you know I got a couple of movies coming
out bad blood and the river guard and we
go back to shoot the final season of
Sons of Anarchy the end of this month
well not sure one final question you're
in a band with the walking wounded is
that right you have some right walking
wounded talking dead yeah from walking
wounded to walking dead that's a nice
progression right great thanks very much
for time have a brilliant day
you